freunde was sich im heutigen video
erlebt habe konnte ich nicht erwarten
und habe ich nicht erwartet wir waren
nämlich in einem dunkelrestaurant haben
das ganze mit einer nachtsichtkamera
gefilmt und für euch somit erlebbar
gemacht aber das krasse war nicht das
essen nicht das schmecken das war auch
vollkommen außergewöhnlich aber viel
mehr diese erfahrung wie es ist in
vollkommener dunkelheit zu existieren
das ist nämlich wirklich eine sache die
kann man sich nicht vorstellen viel spaß
mit dem video sind hier mitten in der
fußgängerzone hier siehst du nichts
steht da schon mitleid ich freue mich
sehr
so sie jetzt angekommen und wir kriegen
zu aller erst einmal eine kleine
einleitung wie das ganze heute
funktioniert weil ich glaube das bedarf
einiger eingehen weil ich kann mir zum
beispiel noch gar nicht vorstellen wie
sollen wir das koordiniert bekommen zu
essen in der absoluten finsternis
ist heute erlaubt und erwünscht also
wenn ich war scherz machen dürften
das ist jan jan hat in seinem
zwanzigsten lebensjahr sein augenlicht
und seine hand verloren und die haben
wir uns den gesamten besuch überführen
wird uns erklären wie es ist wie wir uns
orientieren müssen weil ihr könnt euch
vorstellen wir sind ab dem zeitpunkt wo
wir in dieser absoluten finsternis sind
vollkommen aufgeschmissen und wir können
uns das besser erklären als jan also das
hat er gemacht hat uns ein intro gegeben
und dann ging es auch los
ja hier jetzt los meistens nicht gewusst
und sich nur das schild hier oben durch
er geht gleich zwei möglichkeiten zum
platz zuvor möglichkeit über ein system
findet euer platz selber bitte nicht du
hast gedacht
nein scherz doch nicht so der verband
man sieht ja gar nicht alles sehen nicht
ganz alles aber ich bin von märz trug
das geht nach rechts um die ecke aber
vorsicht walten den kopf höher war ja
heute schon sagen dieser rechts vor
links sind zwei enkel ich würde sagen
hier erfolgt platz finden jetzt musst du
musst du kannst ein bisschen sehen eur
-50 erster eindruck wirklich verrückt es
ist stockdunkel es ist fast dunkler ist
wenn man die augen zu hat ihr könnt euch
nicht vorstellen die dunkel ist da war
es ist nicht so wie wenn ihr in der
nacht aufwacht und keine ahnung da noch
eine steckerleiste leuchtet oder
irgendwie in irgendeiner form ein
bisschen licht gespendet wird vom mond
wie auch immer man es ist dunkel schwarz
also wirklich und eure augen probieren
die ganze zeit dagegen an zu arbeiten
aber ohne erfolg dann haben wir auch
noch gelernt wie sich blinde orientieren
und mit dem wissen konnten wir versuchen
es ihnen gleich zu tun was sich aber als
nicht so einfach herausgestellt hat viel
spaß dabei
wir sind ganz unkompliziert stille
sondern sprudelwasser dann stehen hier
zwei gläser und ich sage viel spaß man
finden
ich habe
gleich ein schicken wir so nicht greift
ich habe jetzt meinen wasser ein
die an conti ich weiß nicht die treppe
lief alles super hier ist bis den
schaden der nähe von meinem ob das ist
jetzt treffe ich gerade
du hast denn ich war schon das mit hier
und jetzt ein glas das ding ist wir
müssen endlich sieht ja durch die
nachtsichtkamera deshalb an der mich
sehen ich kann nicht sehen auf diese
außergewöhnliche
erfahrung geschichten sehr gespannt
gerade auch was ist beim essen wird uns
macht aber das war schon mal ganz gut
geklappt und ich kann nur soviel sagen
ist ein bisschen verrückt was haben wir
dafür einen salat soll ich das jetzt
sagen das ist ja selber rausfinden sehr
schnell ok jetzt auf jeden fall schwer
sage ich mal so dass jetzt kein
blattsalat zu kein leichter sondern der
hat masse auf jeden fall weiß man in
welche aus richtung ich den löffel haben
es krass leute was man direkt für
verlosungs ansätze entwickelt und wie
gut das gehirn dagegen arbeitet dass man
hier wirklich gar nichts sehen kannst du
jetzt wird's spannend
was geschafft dass ich irgendwas auf dem
tisch liegt über ist am besten
leistungen na siehst du dann hier meine
gabel ich nehme mir meine schlüssel am
besten so in die hand zu belassen
wird
ich probiere
ich doch mit platz also das wird mein
gehirn probiert sich so einige
geschmäcker zu klammern weil dadurch
dass ich wirklich gar nicht sehen kann
was hier ist zwischen im wahrsten sinne
des wortes und blind tasting schmecke
ich also gefühlt auch direkt in sie
intensiver weil ich viel konzentrierter
schmecke nicht wahnsinnig ausgefallen
wir haben doch einen blattsalat da ist
ein bisschen hässlich dann hat er gerade
zum käse das war so ein bisschen wie ein
reifer käse gouda vielleicht war auch
schon recht
ich für dich das video des jahres auf
jeden fall denn ich freue mich auch sehr
mich selbst dabei zu sehen war jetzt
gerade es ist ihr könnt euch nicht
vorstellen wie das ist leute das ist
nicht als wird ihr die augen zumachen
das ist als würdet ihr nacht weit und
breit keine laterne kann nichts und dann
macht ihr die augen zu damit sind wir
auf jeden fall traditionell unterwegs
wie gesagt essig öl nichts wahnsinnig
ausgefallen ist bisschen käse bisschen 1
drin ja ich bin der king ist dann eben
ne
na.de leute machen ein tisch voll
gemacht ja ich dachte du ich hab es
nicht mal gehört dass liefert genommen
hat der salat war so ein klassischer
gemischter salat paprika drin meist in
gurke tomate also der wahl addition
elvis' meint es schon so ein klassischer
gemischter salat man auch so im brauhaus
genauso bestellen können durch jahre aus
man scania man aber schon interessant
wie machen das natürlich sowieso immer
ein bisschen sinnieren über das essen
aber ich finde durch diese erfahrung
dass im dunkeln für essen ist das noch
viel mehr noch viel authentischer auch
dass man so darüber nach dem was ist da
drin das schmeckt wie man erlebt dass
auf jeden fall noch mal anders also ich
habe auch das gefühl vielleicht ist das
auch placebo welt er habe erwartet dass
ja auch ein stück weit von diesem
erlebnis intensiver zu schmecken auch so
dieses brot einfach es wäre interessant
mal dass genau das gleiche ding in sehnt
zu probieren neuer dass man wirklich
nicht haben oder gar keins ist
abgeschlossen ein gemischter salat mit
pizza brot alles schmeckt wahnsinnig
intensiv das ist eine herausforderung
die aber sehr viel spaß macht das ganze
zu essen und zu koordinieren und
herauszuschmecken was wie ich freue mich
umso mehr auf den hauptgang
essen für euch ich stell dir einfach mal
das essen auf den tisch sagt
finde ich habe ich auch in essen
geruchlich sehe ich mich in so einem
wirtshaus traten große aber auch eine
gute portion also weißt du was ich die
ganze zeit für gefühl hatte noch bevor
hier probiert ich habe das gefühl wir
sitzen hier so ein absolut dunkel und
der der jahn und erschafft könnten
sinken
so fühlt sich das an aber fühlt sich
genauso verhält sich das leben draußen
habe ich das gefühl alle plötzlich abend
er hier habe ich einen vorteil dann
wollen wir mal drauf los legen
ich richte mich nach so heftiger kost
erster eindruck kartoffelkloß
will ich kannte ich kriege es ja nicht
eingeschätzt wie es geformt ist
kartoffeln sind das haben wir hier
drüben ist irgendwas großes was ich
jetzt schneiden das wird und raten sein
das ist so ein bisschen schmeckt ein
bisschen wieso kein geschnetzeltes aber
es ist ja offensichtlich nicht
geschnetzeltes
kannst du erkennen was es ist können die
zuschauer ganz nicht erkennen also man
kann formen erkennen soll man sich dass
man gar keine farbe sieht es auch
trotzdem schwebt ja wie gar nicht wissen
wie gärten und keller aussieht
wir haben hier einmal so
schweineschnitzel aber nicht paniert
seiner rahmen so ist so schwer dass so
zu dessen schneidig klick dich rein wo
normalerweise siehst du das und
kartoffelbrei hebst du mit der gabel was
raus musste erstmal die einzelnen
komponenten auf dem teller bestimmen
also mein lachen soll keiner weise
irgendwie so premiere und wirken oder so
ich find's einfach nur witzig wie
genau so
[Musik]
witzig wie plus du aussiehst weil du es
einfach nicht kannst du hast einfach
nicht die erfahrung um du lernst gerade
so innerhalb von minuten damit umzugehen
das ist wirklich schwer das ganze auch
für das video zu kommentieren zu fassen
probieren auch begreifbar zu machen für
die zuschauer weil es so wahnsinnig hier
ist kohlrabi
[Musik]
das fruchtige sub vielleicht schmeckt
super gut also können wir die auflösung
einmal ganz kurz haben von unseren höre
ich
überschreite wie die jungs überbacken
mit anna das cocktailkleid kartoffeln
als büros kartoffeln geschwenkt
es schmeckt auch wirklich so als würde
man eine gute küche einfach in die sonne
ehrlich küche diese
geschmackswahrnehmung wie man so die
einzelnen komponenten auch völlig
hilflos probiert zu erschmecken man
denkt ja manchmal sogar schmeckt alles
raus dass durch eine sache die ich
gerade hier feststellen diese illusion
ja man kann sachen raus schmecken du
kannst du zur prägnante gewürze bei
irgendwelchen gericht mehr aus schmecken
wenn er irgendwie kreuzkümmel drin ist
oder so was aber ich konnte gerade nicht
so wirklich gut schwein von hähnchen und
wahrscheinlich konnte nicht gut birne ab
von ananas unterscheiden was es will ich
ganz ganz verrückt aber es schmeckt auf
jeden fall sehr intensiv und sehr gute
leute ich sehe gerade zum ersten mal
dass die kamera ist ja wahnsinn du
kannst du die ganze zeit alles sehen ja
jetzt sind krank was habe ich davon hier
auf dem
teller
die ganze zeit gegen du hast die ganze
liga geschafft
[Gelächter]
ich liebe halt diese saucen
es wirklich supergut schöne rustikale
küche ersten das ganze jetzt auf und
sehen uns zum dessert
schokolade aber es ist nicht eiskalt
also
und ein schwächeres dick ist klar es
muss
[Musik]
schokolade ich glaube da kann man mich
jetzt nicht täuschen können süßen nicht
sehr cremig nicht so süß hat wirklich
bist du findest kaspi ich kein rad durch
richtig klar schmecken einfach das muss
man auch sagen die portionen sind also
durch großzügig man wird ja auch wer
versagt auch also ich bisher ebenfalls
sehr sehr lecker und sowie gezielt man
das ganze schmecken kann passt nämlich
wirklich aber vielmehr faszinierend
eigentlich dass wir auch gelernt haben
heute alles also wichtig waren sind eine
letzte frage habe ich noch insbesondere
in dicht jahren wie bisher mit 20 jahren
blind geworden wie hat sich dann die
wahrnehmung von essen für dich verändert
weil ich habe das gefühl das ist ja
sowieso schon immer erlebnis essen und
das ist ja so wie ich das jetzt so
intensiv geschmeckt habe könnte ich mir
vorstellen dass das umso größeres event
für dich geworden zu essen ja also für
mich ist es essen ihren wichtiger
geworden und auch ich achte mehr auf den
geschmack aller dinge okay das konnte
ich mir nämlich vorstellen also ich habe
wo ich heute wahnsinnig viel geschmeckt
wahnsinnig gut geschmeckt und es hat
wahnsinnig gelöscht deshalb danke schön
für alles wird sagen wir beenden den
teil von videos jetzt hier und sehen uns
gleich ganz kurz zum auto im büro wieder
danke danke herr strafe natürlich
erlebnis und ich danke euch auch schön
dass sie hier rat und sich dann bei euch
für das tolle video dass hier bei uns
gemacht habt und hoffe dass bald ganz
ganz viele gäste wollten zur besucher
also ich habe ja gerade schon gesagt
noch mal herzlichen herzlichen dank es
war eine überwältigende erfahrung auch
jetzt einen tag später ich habe allen
davon erzählt es war wirklich und ich
lege es jedem nahe das auszuprobieren
kölner straße 2 in siegen ist das
dunkelrestaurant indem wir waren es gibt
natürlich auch noch weitere und wirklich
macht das weil das essen bei einer
erlebnis aber das ganze drumherum wir
saßen dort drei stunden und haben
einfach einblicke bekommen die wichtig
sind und die man sonst nicht bekommen
deshalb große empfehlung von mir danke
schön wir sehen uns beim nächsten video
wieder persönlicher koch am sonntag wird
cool bis dahin macht's gut